jetzt kann ich hier wirklich eine
gesichtserkennung hinzufügen bei einem
handy was 62 euro kostet da bin ich
schon finde ich dass die leute was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
gut für ungefähr vor einer woche kam das
video ich habe alle apple produkte von
hughes gekauft was ganz gut bei euch
angekommen ist ich hab gesehen hat ein
paar des lecks weiß ich nicht warum aber
gut wie soll so oder halt mehr des lecks
als sonst in dem video ging es unter
anderem auch um eine fake apple watch
die extrem nice weigern sich die habe
ich letztens schon in dem extra video
getestet weil das viele von euch gefragt
haben ich habe es auch angeboten und ich
habe sehr viele kommentare gesehen dass
sich doch auch mal bitte das fake iphone
11 froh ein bisschen ausführlicher
testen soll weil wir haben das im video
halt wirklich nur 34 minuten getestet
und so features wie kamera face id und
so was das ding mitbringen soll noch
einmal ganz kurz für euch um dieses
produkt hier geht es so sieht das aus
hat mich 62 euro gekostet also wirklich
extrem günstig ich habe ja schon mal
damals zum iphone war irgendein iphone
feld bestellt ich weiß nicht welche
version es war das hat auf jeden fall
über 100 euro gekostet genauso sieht das
ungefähr aus ich hatte es ja auch schon
mal in den händen muss ich glaube ich
auch nicht mehr so viel zu sagen bringt
8 gb speicher mit kann durch 128 weitere
erweitert werden und 1 genau das hier
wollte ich noch mal kurz angehen wir
haben wir zum beispiel den satz front 13
megapixel makes you are beautiful
beautiful
wer kennt es nicht dieses beauty das
macht dich nicht nur more beautiful
es macht dich more beautiful beautiful
schön wenn es da steht ob das wirklich
so ist mag dich selbst zu bezweifeln und
was ich auch noch gesehen habe ganz
interessant unlocking fingerprint faces
da würde ich auch mal sehr kritisch
gegenüber eingestellt trotzdem war der
erste eindruck im letzten part ganz gut
für dieses geld ja drei sterne
bewertungen danke immer wieder gerne
danke also die leute die das kaufen die
haben auch manchmal absoluten
dachschaden oder danke immer wieder
gerne dank naja er reift für den preis
ist okay leider ist die kamera
minderwertig aha na schauen wir mal rein
für den preis ist es okay leider ist die
kamera minderwertig einweiht
gewitterfront ort der ist ja nett
gibt es hier immer meinen zuschauern
wobei das auch schon los ist auf
instagram ihr sonst immer alles verlost
alex heiß ich dort fangen wir jetzt auch
mal an ich habe mir hier noch ein iphone
11 besorgt haben das vielleicht ein
bisschen zu vergleichen ich bin nicht an
ein iphone 11 pro gekommen so schnell
das tut mir ein bisschen leid aber gut
okay leute also ich hab jetzt noch eine
zweite kamera installiert das will ich
gar nicht mehr lange lagern wir starten
jetzt packen das noch mal aus schauen
uns alles an vergleichen dann ein
bisschen okay was macht die verwaltung
auf direkt oben drin liegt das
wunderschöne handy welches ja so
aussieht
wir haben hier oben diese drei kameras
die man auch beim iphone 11 pro
vorfindet das sieht auch wirklich sehr
identisch aus muss ich sagen kann ich
euch sehr gerne hier mal kurz zeigen
also wenn man sich das ganze so anguckt
und dann vergleichen da kommt es schon
halbwegs hin
ihr fehlt halt nur leider das apple-logo
hier steht irgendwas von hd kamera noch
mit buy dann würde ich nicht wirklich
sagen damals bei dem anderen iphone war
das viel besser also der erste eindruck
so kann hier sehr gerne mal das iphone
11 daneben legen
ja also ich will jetzt noch die dritte
kamera dann kommt das ja ungefähr hin
ich weiß nicht also ein paar
unterschiede kann man halt direkt
erkennen die ja eigentlich bei einem
guten fake nicht erkennbar sein sollten
so viele fakes wie ich schon getestet
habe aber gut vielleicht überrascht es
mich ja doch noch positiv von vorne
sieht dann so aus dass man auch sagen ja
gut hier kann man jetzt auch den
nächsten unterschied sehen hierbei der
front kämpft sieht halt ein bisschen
anders als beim originalen
originalversion aber gut da drücken wir
mal beide augen zu ich habe nichts
gesehen
es ist immer noch ganz klar ein iphone
elf fei da hinten ja okay okay dann
mache ich das jetzt noch mal an das habe
ich ja bereits auch im letzten video
jetzt achtung jetzt werde ich wieder
schockiert sein hilfe aber da kann ich
ja gar nicht hingucken kommt auch dieser
eklige ton
genau htc 2010 habe ich auch beim
letzten mieter schon gesagt also da war
ich dann erstmal geschockt als ich das
gehört habe
jetzt ist es gleich nochmal hochgefahren
nach ein paar jahren genau perfekt also
sieht das jetzt aus muss ich sagen da
war ich schon überrascht als ich das zum
ersten mal hochgefahren habe das ist
wirklich hier dieser apple icons hat
können wir gerne mal vergleichen ich
habe die sprache bei dem verklingen auch
gerade schon auf deutsch umgestellt das
war nämlich vor englisch gut also ich
weiß nicht ob ihr das so deutlich sehen
könnt aber es reagiert schon nicht so
nice wie hier das beim originalen dingen
der fall ist
das ist natürlich alles ein bisschen
smuda genauso wie bei der apple watch
aber es ist halt auch nur ein billiger
trick leute was ich gerade auch gesehen
habe die apps heißen hier
unterschiedlich beim originalen heißt es
zum beispiel sprachmemos beim feld
heißes sound recorder war das mal so
dass damals beim iphone das ganze also
diese memo app oder die sprache sound
recorder hieß ich weiß es nicht ich
glaube nicht oder oder erinnerungen
heißt halt eiskalt aufgabe so
erinnerungen und aufgabe okay doch was
man noch als aufgabe zu tun hat ja ja
man kann es schon so ein bisschen
nachvollziehen aber da fällt es halt
auch so ein bisschen das liegt natürlich
auch daran
wir haben hier keinen ios drauf sondern
irgendwo einen android das ist
schrecklich mal kurz android 9.1 das ist
ja gar nicht mal so veraltet oder guckt
das neueste ist android 10
veröffentlicht am dritten september 2019
also da bin ich soll ich mir schon ein
bisschen überrascht deswegen weil ich
nicht ganz warum das so komischen namen
hat also aufgabe anstatt änderung aber
gut als erstes würde ich mich gern mal
an die face iran machen weil da stand ja
ganz klar face id im kann man aktivieren
gar kein problem so sicherheit display
sperre gesichtserkennung alter da ist es
ja auch schon
ich habe es direkt gesehen gesichts
daten registrieren
sperre einen alter jetzt kann ich hier
wirklich was ich zeig euch mal hier in
der kamera jetzt kann ich hier wirklich
eine gesichtserkennung hinzufügen bei
einem handy was 62 euro kostet da bin
ich schon finde ich neues registrierung
staaten das muss aber natürlich auch
erst mal funktionieren ihr telefon kann
unter umständen von einer ähnlich
aussehende person oder mit einem
entsprechenden ähnlichen gegenstand
entsperrt gegenstand ok egal wir machen
das jetzt mal
angemeldet das war's schon okay das
heißt ich habe das jetzt praktisch
gesperrt das mache ich es nochmal an und
könnte jetzt einfach hier nach oben
vision pin eingeben nenne ich würde ja
mit gesichts das gesicht wird gescannt
und es geht es funktioniert genial
altert das hätte ich ohne scheiß da muss
ich sagen hut ab hätte ich gar nicht mal
gedacht
wobei das natürlich auch bei fast allen
geräten die jetzt raus kommen natürlich
funktionieren sollte nur 62 euro günstig
gut da würde ich sagen als nächstes
checken varma die kamera wollte ich auch
auf jeden fall machen das haben auch
sehr viele von euch geschrieben dass ich
das noch mal machen soll wie hieß es so
schön euro gesichtserkennung
fehlgeschlagen 3 10 megapixel face
kamera macht dein gesicht motive
beautiful schauen wir mal okay und hier
muss ich jetzt wirklich sagen dieses
system hier erinnert noch ganz ganz
stark an ganz ganz veraltete iphone ja
mal gucken welcher sound da jetzt kommt
ok den sound kann ich gar nicht aha na
gut also ich mache einfach mal ein foto
gerne auch noch ein foto mit der
frontkämpfer komme ich fotografiere mal
hier meinen schönen hintergrund und das
gleiche mache ich jetzt auch mal kurz
mit dem originalen iphone hier dessen
kamera ja absolut genial ist gut okay
das zeige ich euch dann jetzt einmal
hier der fake hier vom original könnt
ihr euch selber eine meinung bilden
natürlich meine erkenntnis gigantischen
unterschied trotzdem hätte ich ist für
62 euro noch für deutlich deutlich
deutlich schlechter eingeschätzt muss
ich sagen vor allem die face cam hat
mich überrascht hier auch respekt hätte
ich nicht gedacht was ich auf jeden fall
auch noch sagen wollte natürlich jetzt
hier man sieht erstmal die ganzen apple
icons alles schön und gut auch wenn der
android-version drauf ist trotzdem hätte
ich dann auch erwartet dass wenn man zum
beispiel hier in die einstellung geht
hier sieht man ja dann direkt okay das
ist überhaupt nicht
ios das ist ganz klar irgendein
android-betriebssystem ich glaube da
hätte man sich die arbeit machen können
das auch ein bisschen umzuprogrammieren
so dass auch das hier aussieht wie ein
ios system im großen und ganzen das ist
halt irgendwie so ein halbfertiges
gepflegtes iphone
ja also da fehlt noch so viel was man
sagen kann ok ihr habt jetzt ein iphone
kopiert so ich weiß ich habe in dem
letzten video wo ich das zum ersten mal
kurz vorgestellt habe eigentlich
ausschließlich nur gutes dazu gesagt und
das ist vermutlich wirklich besser sich
so ein gerät für 62 euro zu kaufen
anstatt dass ihr jetzt irgendwie zu
media-markt fahrt und euch da ins aus
spielt 450 weil da tut sich nicht viel
ich glaube mich jetzt noch mal kurz hier
einmal kurz ein video von mir zu
rekorden um dann auch den sound zu
checken und jo leute was geht ich drehe
gerade in den ices videofilmen
youtube-kanal den ihr auf jeden fall
alle abonnieren sollte okay aufgenommen
mit einem toaster
das sind dann immer so könnt ihr diese
absoluten mystischen videos oder
irgendwelche mordfälle wo dann gesagt
wird okay wir haben aber noch die
überwachungskamera und dann wird so ein
video abgespielt bei dem man fast gar
nichts erkennt wo man sich immer fragt
warum gibt es da keine vor den kameras
ja ich glaube im oftmals werden dann
diese handys antennen verwendet weil die
kamera um jetzt videos aufzunehmen und
auch der sound davon ist absolut
katastrophal ich hatte auch mal so ein
alcatel handy für 70 80 euro oder so die
marke wird wahrscheinlich eher der
älteren generation von euch was sagen
das habe ich dann meiner oma geschenkt
so als wir senioren handy heute kommen
sie mal mit arbeiten und da war der
sound auf jeden fall besser das video an
sich auch ja ich frage mich sowieso was
diese drei kameras hintendrauf bringen
weil besondere funktionen haben die ja
nicht auto aufnahme bei lächelerkennung
wie damals bei den ganz alten
digitalkamera ist jetzt fällt mir gerade
auf das galerie icon ist auch von
android und nennt sich hier auch fotos
also irgendwer hat er komplett blödsinn
gemacht die hälfte wird übernommen
für ios die andere hälfte ist android
geblieben also vom look hat yahoo com
als kann ich das foto hier noch mit
verschiedenen effekten füllen was dann
wahrscheinlich auch die drei kameras
erklärt
also da kann man alles dann noch
aufholen die sind ganz ganz wichtig im
tiefenunschärfe vorstellen wie es ja
beim neuen iphone lv geht ja auch das
kann dieses handy garantiert nicht auch
hier die tastatur hat natürlich absolut
gar nichts mit ios zu tun hat sieht aus
wie bei jedem android gerät touch
funktioniert aber an sich ganz neues
also man kann vernünftig schreiben muss
ich auch ein auge zu
drücken also wir halten wir fest wir
haben ein fake iphone 11 pro welches vom
design her bis auf die drei kameras
hintendrauf nicht unbedingt wie ein
iphone heraus sieht die
gesichtserkennung funktioniert
komischerweise wunderbar die kamera ist
auch in ordnung außer man macht videos
dann könnte man das er in die tonne
hauen wenn wir das gerät einsperren so
erhalten wir na ja auf den ersten blick
vielleicht irgendwas was im iphone
ähnelt wenn man das ganze dann genauer
unter die lupe nimmt gibt es ganz ganz
viele sachen die gar nichts mit iphone
zu tun haben und somit muss ich im
großen und ganzen schon sagen finde ich
es ein bisschen krass dieses dingen als
fake iphone 11 pro darzustellen hat halt
nur sehr sehr wenig damit zu tun aber
trotzdem für 62 euro
ein absolut vernünftiges gerät mit dem
man arbeiten kann
akku hält auch lange alter das ding in
lack ist hier eine woche rum der akku
war nicht mal halb voll und ist jetzt
immer noch bei der hälfte muss ich sagen
also ich verlinke euch gerne in der
video schreibung für die leute die sowas
mit so etwas anfangen können ich weiß
nicht ob es da wir hier gibt bestimmt
check das sehr gern ab und mit dem
gutscheincode alex 1 gibt es noch bis
ende märz 25 prozent rabatt bayerisch
ansonsten hoffe ich der test hat euch
bis hierhin gefallen ich habe mein
bestes gegeben um euch noch mal ein
vernünftiges zu geben haut rein wir
sehen uns dann am sonntag wieder gibt es
neues video um 19 uhr das war's